oh cool
no no don't come on vacation Ned those
dozen refugees get around
on the job
okay
this is mr. Veeck he's from earth just
not house the snap to our home in our
dimension you're saying that you've
multiverse awesome start left these for
you hello Peter would you like to see
what I can do initiating strength
initiating what now
spider-man bought from home let's see
how they look you know I could blow you
up right now yeah they'd still look
terrible
oh I need a suit suit you take care of
the suit I'll take care of the music I
forgot I can teach my face and then
there's the stealth suit which is my
favorite suit because it's totally
different and totally fresh the idea
behind the suit is Peter Parker doesn't
want to be seen as spider-man in Europe
so Nick Fury loans him this costume
something out the shield special locks
world how's the suit mister it's great
it's awesome it's kind of Captain
America like with a spider-man twist do
you think it's pirate no no no it's like
a European ripoff version of them I was
actually reading about the other day
it's not and it also looks pretty bad
so the black and red suit is fight
wearing a work of art it looks so
realistic that it feels like you should
be able to climb walls and you should be
able to shoot webs and the way that it's
made is for no marsh to the godfather of
the MCU the world needs the next Iron
Man
hi everyone its charlie were just a
little ways away from spider-man far
from home coming out we have a bunch of
new clips a bunch of new shots of the
new suits and Mysterio just totally
making fun of spider-man because he
thinks the Iron Man glasses are lame and
some really cool Iron Man technology
that we did not know about so we'll
break it down there's a new round of
that IMAX ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a spider-man comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this there's a lot of other Avengers
stuff going on that I'll reference at
the end of the video but remember there
is that extra cut with the new post
credit scene I'll be talking about that
later this weekend - we get a brand new
spider-man and Mysterio versus hydro-man
clip then we get that special clip a
more extended version of the clip with
the Iron Man glasses where it gets them
and he sees what everyone's looking at
on their smartphones that's basically
what the Iron Man glasses are doing the
AI is pulling data from everyone's
smartphones so it sees what people are
texting to other people it hears the
conversations that it's having if you
notice the person that everyone's
thinking is the chameleon the actor here
sitting in the front that's on Nick
Fury's team his text bubble actually has
red that's blurred out in it there was a
similar clip a little while ago that I
did a video for just explaining what's
going on in all these different chat
bubbles and what the people are talking
about in his was completely blank so
it's not a spoiler to say this person is
actually a team member with Nick Fury
special team you see him in the
background of all these shots when
spider-man is meeting Mysterio for the
first time but then you learn about the
very special Ironman technology that's
also built into it where he almost
accidentally calls in an orbital strike
from a stark tech satellite one of the
many many stark tech satellites that are
orbiting the earth so that he has
anything available to him at any time
remember that's where he kept Veronica
aka the Hulkbuster during Avengers age
of Ultron I'm calling a Veronica
this satellite isn't Veronica though
he's not calling down the Hulkbuster is
just another satellite in the same way
that he called for the special iron
spider suit to come from the New
Avengers facility
he gave Friday the special codes so that
she would know which one to eject it
came in to outer space but the film
trades a lot on the legacy of Tony Stark
and what have they used in previous
films like Avengers age of Ultron is
also a really good example where the
legacy of his time as a weapons dealer
becomes very heavy on him like oh this
is all coming back to bite me in the ass
me selling all these weapons of mass
destruction there's still a lot of stark
orbital weapons platforms around the
earth ready at a moment's notice to just
rain down fire any time Ironman or any
time a warlord has bought weapons from
Tony Stark wants to use them and has the
money to buy an orbital weapons platform
the other really cool thing too is that
any of Tony Stark's AIS that he's
created have the ability to hack in to
other stark tech there's a certain
baseline code that he builds into all of
his technology that gives him access to
all stark tech all over the world even
if it's something that he's sold to
someone years ago it's just a standard
defense mechanism if someone were to try
to attack him with his own technology he
would have a way to override that the
thing about Spider Man now is that he's
just discovering all these special
little hidden Easter eggs that Tony
Stark never told him about like oh yeah
there's all this hidden code here you
can hack into all this really cool stuff
they have the funny scene of Mysterio
and the bar shading him just telling him
the glasses look kind of stupid this is
also that same scene where Spiderman
names him an Avenger
welcome to The Avengers I'm sure this
won't go terribly there's a much longer
scene of him making the new black and
red suit which we're just calling the
Steve Ditko suit they do a whole big
feature ed there's a couple other funny
clips built in there too but you get a
much better look at it up close it's
awesome it's kind of Captain America
like with a spider-man twist the reason
why he's calling the stealth suit a
Captain America
style suit like it's very much in the
vein of Captain America suit is because
it doesn't have all the really cool
technology built into it the way that
the stark tech suits do or the iron
spider suit remember even Captain
America's Avengers endgames suit the
final one he wore was still a bit of an
Armour of
rade stronger materials but it didn't
have a lot of technology built into it
the civil war suit was also a bit of a
downgrade from the Avengers age of
Ultron suit the extra tech that he had
built into the age of Ultron suit were
just the special suit magnets built into
the wrist gauntlets in the back just to
help him use his shield without the need
of the strap the reason why they went
back to the strap for avengers endgame
is because it was more iconic incap was
meant to be the most iconic version of
himself during that wearing this really
cool comic book II looking armor using
the classic shield with the strap so
that he could have that moment the scene
where he cinches it even though Santa's
has already chopped out a giant chunk of
the vibranium shield because his sword
is that strong I don't think it would
look better if he would had a whole
bunch of extra technology there Thor's
hammer was meant to be the really
special thing and quick sidenote - we
actually just found out about all the
deleted scenes and the bonus features
that'll be on the Avengers end game
blu-ray I'll remind people about that at
the end of the video Tom Holland calls
Robert Downey jr. Z Iron Man character
The Godfather of the MCU like we wanted
to have this homage to The Godfather of
the MCU when Peter is building his brand
new spider-man suit if you notice here
in the background you can actually see
that there are four different suits that
he cycles through on this display while
he's coming up with a design for the
brand new one there's the comic book
iron spider suit the red and gold
version of the suit the very first
hoodie version of the suit that he built
for himself when he first became
spider-man before the events of Captain
America Civil War then the original
stark tech suit then the fourth version
of the suit the last one you see here is
the combination of the previous three
it's the Steve Ditko red and black suit
so the new suit is basically a mash-up
of all the previous suits with little
Easter eggs built into it made to look
like the very classic Steve Ditko
version of spider-man suit there was a
funny Tom Holland story where he also
talks about calling Robert Downey jr.
The Godfather
that was what he named him just because
he's such a big figure in his life
especially when he first met him but
just to give you an idea of what his
relationship with Robert Downey jr. is
like in real life because he's sort of a
surrogate father to him he was a mentor
on set during Captain America's Civil
War and then during the Avengers movies
just kind of helping him learn the ins
and outs of filmmaking on a basic level
recently Robert Downey jr. was giving an
award to Jon Favreau at
award ceremony just to honor him for all
this special stuff that he's been doing
he wanted Tom Hahn
to record a special message that they
would playback at this award ceremony so
he called him to ask him to make this
and because Tom Holland is on London
time and Robert Downey jr. was on
California time he was calling Tom
Holland in the wee hours of the morning
so he just ghosted him and set him
straight to voicemail without seeing who
it was he woke up the next morning to
see that there was a message on his
voicemail from the Godfather
quote-unquote because Robert Downey jr.
's information in his phone shows up as
The Godfather he freaks out tries to
call him back but because of the time
change Robert Downey jr. was asleep and
he said that it was the most afraid that
he's ever been waiting for him to call
him back
I sent the Godfather to voicemail you
know obviously it's not that big a deal
but it just gives you an idea for how
Tom Holland views Robert Downey jr. in
real life and what their relationship is
like
I think this scene of Ned Lee is trying
to tell Betty Brant about a European
knockoff spider-man because he's wearing
this tell so no that's not spider-man
he's not following us around is meant to
be a reference to the Japanese
spider-man from the 1970s quick Stanley
history lesson in Hollywood so early on
there was a version of the MCU that
Stanley was trying to create in
Hollywood using the Marvel properties
like we have all these characters why
don't we get movies and TV shows going
that's how they got the Hulk TV show
going one of his early successes was in
getting a spider-man TV show going in
the late 70s but it was in Japan so
that's why a lot of people didn't see it
on USA television unless you're watching
it on YouTube or watching clips
somewhere
spider-man
but like I said big stuff coming up this
weekend spider-man far from home
starting on Monday I'll start doing my
Easter eggs and post credit scene in
full review once it hits theaters so no
worries
we also learned exactly what deleted
scenes and bonus features are gonna be
on the Avengers end game blu-ray let me
know if you want me to do a video about
that we learned about possible
taskmaster in the black widow Avengers
prequel movie and that's only the
beginning there's like four or five
other videos that I'm working on so just
let me know which video you want me to
do next so no worries there's a whole
bunch of Marvel stuff coming up
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video mr. Qi
said please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for that new Thor guardians
of the galaxy three teaser and click
here to learn about live-action
spider-man into the spider burst
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you